bonsoir il est 18h sur tv fil 78 le
journal en direct 26 minutes
d'information locale et voici les titres
invités de cette édition et manuel
ferreira responsable pédagogique du
centre d'enseignement des soins
d'urgence dans les yvelines il signe
avec le samu un court métrage pour
sensibiliser à la prise en charge de
l'arrêt cardiaque avec le défibrillateur
automatique les temps d'activités
périscolaires il en est largement
question depuis mardi est la rentrée ce
soir vous verrez concrètement comment se
passent l'un de ces fameux atelier dans
la ville de guyancourt et puis une
institution centenaire et qui compte
plus de 2000 membres contrainte à fermer
le centre de tir national de versailles
doit quitter ces terrains situés sur une
dépendance du château un clin d'oeil
pour débuter cette demi-heure nous
sommes en pleine période des
commémorations des deux principaux
conflits mondiaux et deux boulangeries
des yvelines y participent à leur
manière à à versailles rue de montreuil
et à achères rue de poissy vous pourrez
déguster le pain de 14-18 uniquement
fabriqué pendant la grande guerre il est
remis au goût du jour par ces deux
établissements c'est un meunier arrière
petit neveu d'un boulanger des troupes
pendant le conflit qui est à l'origine
de cette idée on écoute le responsable
de la boutique située sur versailles le
pain de 14,7 un pain qui est fabriqué
avec les farines qu'on trouvait au temps
de la guerre et c'est le meunier qui a
sorti ce produit et nous on le fabrique
et on le cuit sur place
il est un peu plus pas un peu plus plein
moins développés et un petit peu plus
acides
ce qu'on trouve actuellement des routes
embouteillées des automobilistes qui
s'agace une scène assez fréquentes dans
notre région parisienne et même
quotidienne pour ceux qui empruntent le
pont schuller reliant est la verrière à
maurepas la gare 1 et relier le que par
ses deux voies mais un doublement est à
l'étude pour 2016 une réunion publique
vient de se tenir avec les habitants
mercredi soir coût total de ce projet
qui a été présenté 10 millions yolaine
thorez et patrick jacq de dixinn tu le
vois il était au coeur de la réunion
publique mercredi soir à la mairie de
maurepas le pont guy schuller début 2018
ce pont qui relie maurepas à la verrière
en enjambant la n10 sera doublé les
nouvelles voies seront réservés au
passage des bus des piétons et des
cyclistes
l'un des objectifs majeurs désengorger
ce passage souvent saturée aux heures de
pointe
ça représente une bouffée d'air parce
que ça fait des années que ce projet
était dans les tiroirs et puis grâce
aussi à la volonté de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
et puis des élus de la ville de maurepas
et de la verrière donc ce projet abouti
et donc on va pouvoir régler enfin les
les bouchons d'entrée de ville à
maurepas
mais aussi d'améliorer les transports en
commun dans un bassin de vie qui suit
saint quentin pour la commune de la
verrière ce projet s'inscrit dans un
vaste projet urbain de création d'un
nouveau quartier gare bécane le
doublement du pont permettrait notamment
de fluidifier la circulation autour de
cet espace c'est une des étapes de la
reconversion de la zone d'activités de
la revitalisation de la zone d'activité
avec une autre des serbes des
stationnements et là nous repensons des
axes et les stationnements le carrefour
de made me donne et c'est donc c'est un
des éléments du projet global
lors de cette concertation publique le
moment était venu pour les habitants de
questionner le projet qui pour certains
soulève quelques inquiétudes
déjà les nuisances mais après au niveau
des impôts locaux
parce que je pense que c'est à nous nous
a pas loupé
le doublement du consulaire c'est sans
doute une solution valable mais moi ce
que j'attends c'est qu'elles soient
comparés à d'autres
si si elle est vraiment intéressante
point de vue coût au point de vue délai
faisabilité en ce moment tous les matins
et tous les soirs il ya la queue sur le
pont schuller fin du repas en plus d'une
heure ils auraient mené mais enfin
peut-être qu'ils auraient plus est que
le coût prévisionnel des travaux s'élève
pour l'instant à un peu plus de 10
millions d'euros toutes taxes comprises
si vous voulez donner votre avis rendez
vous sur les sites internet de la
communauté d'agglomération de la commune
de maurepas ou encore de la verrière
vous pouvez également vous rendre sur
place et assister à la prochaine réunion
publique le 11 septembre prochain à la
verrière prochaine réunion autour de ce
dossier le 11 septembre ce sera à la
verrière cette fois ci et l'on reparle
dtap ce soir l'étape s'étendent
activités périscolaires les fameuses
animations qui sont proposées en
prolongement du temps de classe
certaines communes ont choisi de les
étaler sur la semaine après les cours
d'autres ont privilégié le décret hamon
qui permet de les regrouper sur une
seule demi-journée à de la semaine mais
à guyancourt
c'est la pause du midi qui est
privilégié voilà pour la théorie dans la
pratique cela se passe comme ça
catherine gil à tort centre de loisirs
poulenc brassens il est midi c'est là où
l'on retrouve des écoliers de guyancourt
pour leurs stands animations
périscolaires
le choix a été fait d'augmenter la pause
2010 et d'offrir la possibilité de jeux
aux enfants comment les principaux
intéressés perçoivent ce nouvel
aménagement dans leur journée nous avons
posé la question à trois d'entre eux et
ils ont déjà bien pris leurs marques
après la cantine par exemple normalement
on avait une cour 2 et 10 minutes
mais maintenant on est une course de 30
minutes c'est mieux parce que
mais a puisé dans pour manger on a plus
de temps à se plonger dans la voix est
là y'a plein de jeux par exemple pour
les cirques
il ya des cerceaux et à des balles il ya
des échasses on peut aller à l'intérieur
il ya des poufs pour s'allonger sur mon
âme à la tête ou le pour se reposer et
aussi des rats une grande cour et on a
plus de temps pour s'amuser il ya des
salles avec des jets société et on peut
faire aussi des dessins accueillir des
enfants plutôt bien renseigné la pause
du midi a donc été allongé de 1h30 à 2h
15 et la mala jeu préparé par les
enfants du conseil municipal des jeunes
au niveau des
des choix ils peuvent plus investir dans
ce qu'ils veulent au fait et ils peuvent
choisir ce qu'ils ont envie de faire
pendant le temps de pause et on les
laisse libres
bien qu'on soit dans un cadre collectif
qui une individualisation des prises en
charge et que l'enfant puisse ou faire
des activités si ça lui faisait plaisir
ou de pouvoir avoir le temps de ne rien
faire ou de lire ou même de s'isoler
dans un coin de la cour du centre
voilà qui c'est vrai ce soit vraiment un
temps personnel qui correspondent à ses
besoins physiologiques soit de repos
soit d'activité pour l'heure les enfants
n'ont pas d'activité attitré ils font
comme ils le souhaitent dans le courant
du mois des animations fixes devraient
leur être proposées progressivement en
fonction de leurs souhaits et des envies
des animateurs pour mettre en place
c'était ap la ville a recruté 20
animateurs supplémentaires et proposer
des contrats pérennes à ceux qui étaient
déjà en place entre 350000 et quatre
cent mille euros c'est le coût estimé
pour la mise en place de cette réforme
coût qui englobe les postes
supplémentaires et l'achat de matériel
lui en cours compte 26 écoles réparties
sur 15 groupes scolaires les temps
d'activités périscolaires se mettant en
place c'est un autre chantier qui va
s'ouvrir pour l'éducation celui de
l'évaluation des élèves l'idée est de
les encourager et non plus de les
stigmatiser par deux mauvaises notes
c'est en tout cas ce que pensent
certains que vous soyez ou non d'accord
vous pourrez en tout cas le faire savoir
au sein et d'un jury amenée à livrer des
conclusions argumenté qui seront ensuite
remises à la nouvelle ministre de
l'éducation pour devenir membre de ce
jury envoyer votre candidature à
l'adresse et qui s'est affiché 30
personnes parents élèves enseignants
seront à sélectionner et d'ici la fin du
mois de septembre le tribunal
administratif de versailles a ordonné
l'expulsion du club 2/3 national de
versailles du terrain à des mortemets un
terrain appartenant au château la
nouvelle est tombée comme un couperet
pour les usagers le mois dernier même
s'il y avait déjà des signes
annonciateurs ces derniers mois et c'est
anthony rech qui fait le point ces deux
passionnés tire probablement leur
dernière balle au club de tir nationale
le tribunal administratif de versailles
a ordonné il ya quelques semaines
l'expulsion du club installé depuis 1876
sur le camp de morte mais dépendances du
château de versailles château qui
invente un programme de conservation du
patrimoine sur la zone
martenet dans ce cas-là l'expulsion elle
est plus que probable j'allais dire
beaucoup plus que si c'était un terrain
privé le terrain public il a pour
vocation de servir l'intérêt général en
l'occurrence le château de versailles à
des projets des projets qui sont
relatifs au réaménagement de ces
parcelles pour à titre de promenade pour
les piétons les cyclistes je crois une
expulsion qui priverait de cibles plus
de 1500 licenciés
la convention d'occupation des lieux
entre l'établissement public du château
de versailles et la fédération française
de tir a pris fin en juillet 2012
à l'origine le club devait déménager sur
le plateau de satory en cas d'obtention
des jeux par paris
faute de terrain de repli la fédération
n'a pas bougé depuis la décision du
tribunal administratif
elle risque une astreinte de 1000 euros
par jour de toute façon on cherche à
partir parce qu'on sait très bien qu'on
ne restera pas ici donc retrouver
quelque chose qui correspondait faut
trouver quelque chose qui soit dans un
environnement où il est on crée pas de
nuisances aux gens qui habitent déjà là
qui réside la fin où toutes sortes de
choses comme ça quoi donc c'est pas
facile on désire rester quand même dans
les yvelines
trois destinations potentielles
yvelinois sont à l'étude à l'heure
actuelle au morte mais le club occupe
plus de 4 hectares en attendant le tir
nationale a lancé une pétition contre
cette expulsion qui a recueilli plus de
vingt mille signatures en à peine un
mois la fédération et de clubs ou fait
appel du jugement mais la solution
pourrait bien être d'origine politique
le club est utilisé par la gendarmerie
et la police pour l'entraînement il sert
donc lui aussi l'intérêt général
reportage vous l'avez entendu d'anthony
rêche et de clerck ambiel arrêts
respiratoires concernaient 10% des
treize mille interventions annuelles du
smur des yvelines et en attendant les
secours face à une telle situation il
faut savoir réagir vite d'où l'idée de
ce court métrage baptisé action visible
depuis plusieurs semaines déjà sur
internet on en parle ce soir avec
emmanuel pereira bonsoir bonsoir et
bienvenue en plateau pour le journal de
téléphiles responsable du centre
d'enseignement des soins d'urgence le
cesu 78 à l'origine donc avec le samu du
département de ce fameux courts métrages
dont on va voir rapidement les images
d'ailleurs on va situer à peut-être
l'action le scénario de quoi il s'agit
ça se passe lors du tournage d'un film
un comédien est un peu maltraité par son
réalisateur et puis finalement il va se
révéler comme étant un véritable leader
lorsque va arriver l'arrêt cardiaque de
son partenaire de jeu voilà tout à fait
c'est le mauvais qui devient très bon et
qui permet de sauver la vie c'est
quelque chose qui peut arriver dans la
vie quotidienne c'est quelque chose qui
arrive dans la vie quotidienne faux
leaders comme ça quelqu'un qui sache
tout de suite quoi faire ah oui plus on
va plus on va agir vite plus on va
gagner de temps et meilleures seront les
chances de récupération
donc si on a la chance d'avoir un leader
qui prend tout de suite les choses en
main on améliore le pronostic
on va voir un extrait du court métrage
juste pour préciser que vous avez
travaillé avec des comédiens
professionnels
jackie berroyer elle dans le noir louise
chabat la fille d'alain chabat aussi et
qui se lance dans la comédie qui importe
qui ont participé ils sont arrivés comme
ans sur ce projet moi ils sont arrivés
on les a contactés ils ont ils ont tous
assez rapidement dit oui et vous me
donnez l'occasion de les remercier ainsi
que les techniciens toutes les personnes
qui ont participé à ce court métrage
parce qu'ils ont travaillé quasiment
bénévolement
sinon on n'aurait pas pu on aurait pu
avoir le budget ils ont travaillé donc
quasiment bénévolement et avec un grand
emprunt ce qui fait qu'on a pu réaliser
ce court métrage court métrage dont on
va regarder à présent un extrait il est
visible sur internet s'ils ne vous
l'avez pas encore elle découvert voici
un long extrait on reparle juste après
aussi de votre travail le but c'est de
sensibiliser
il faut savoir connaître les gestes qui
sauvent et pouvoir sauver des vies c'est
finalement assez simple lorsqu'on a les
bons réflexes silence auguste est ce que
tu m'entends il fermement contre j'en
passe on souffre sur mon visage je
l'entends pas l'air qui sort je vois pas
ma main bouge et il est inconscient il
respire pas c'est un arrêt cardiaque
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait julien qu'est-ce qu'on fait alban
jacky appelle le samu en composant le 15
e l'adresse explique la situation
la situation oui un homme 38 enfin un
arrêt cardiaque
on va débuter la réanimation à l'aider
butoir robin tulard audiard à l'entrée
du studio ya un défibrillateur recherché
branchement ce massage cardiaque
ok et ma commune et du thorax et bras
bien tendus et perpendiculaires 100 fois
par minute
il arrive c'est bon c'est bon et pas
tous quand je vais le tuer non qu'il
faut enfoncer le thorax de 4 à 6 cm tu
peux me chanter son single like s'il te
plait je déconne pas du tout c'est un
rythme parfait pour un massage cardiaque
entre 100 et 120 pression par minute
leur frère à aa
c'est une malade ces gars là bas à aa
tu es là
à
oh
dans ce court métrage il ya un ton
décalé le message est sérieux mais vous
vouliez qui est un petit peu ce décalage
souris de but c'était de dédramatiser un
peu la situation qui parfois voilà on se
dit l'arrêt cardiaque c'est pour les
spécialistes c'est pour ces pour le samu
c'est pour les docteurs c'est pour les
sapeurs pompiers alors que bon on a
essayé de dédramatiser une situation qui
est qui qui peut être dramatique pour
pour pas qu'on ait ce blocage justement
et avec des gestes très simples essayer
d'améliorer la prise en charge de désert
et cardiaque en france ce qui se dit ce
qui se fait dans le film c'est ça qu'il
faut appliquer dans la vie quotidienne
ou les avait guidé aussi les acteurs
vous avez veillé à ce que ce soit fidèle
à la réalité le but est pas de montre et
n'importe quoi oui bien sûr dans la
construction du scénario on a on a
utilisé les termes exacts que nous on
réutilise en formation tous les jours et
puis on a travaillé beaucoup avec alban
pour pour justement que les gestes
soient les bons ce qu'on voit à l'image
de ce qu'on entend c'est exactement ce
qu'il faut même les bitches même les
bitches
parce que comme le dit alban c'est
exactement le rythme parfait on doit
masse est appuyée entre 100 et 120 et
les bee gees staying alive
c'est à 108 selon les versions entre 105
et 108 selon les versions donc c est qu
on est exactement dans le créneau donc
oui il faut chanter les bee gees quand
on fait du match car les amateurs de
disco ils peuvent aussi se reconvertir
dans le secourisme pourquoi pas là on ne
voit pas souvent en france ce type de
réalisation c'est même plutôt une
première mais vous me disiez avoir les
missions que ça se faisait en revanche
plus à l'étranger oui ça c'est fait nono
a mis neuf les britanniques ont fait la
british heart
foundation a fait un film avec vinnie
jones aussi avec avec ce ton un peu
décalé dans le même but de dredd
dédramatiser les nord américains l'ont
fait aussi voilà c'est bien accueillie
par les professionnels parce qu'en
france justement y avait pas cette cette
réserve
nous on a bien accueilli les films
anglo-saxons
ce qui d'ailleurs nous allons s'est
inspiré de sa pour pour le faire en
français et avec le défibrillateur qui
n'existe pas dans les autres
non les autres films et le retour qu'on
a depuis que le film est en ligne sur
internet est plutôt bon mais plutôt
encourageant en disant oui c'est utile
c'est très utile il faudrait le diffuser
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
maintenant pour le retrouver si vous
voulez le voir en intégralité
rendez-vous aussi sur le site du cesu
cesu 78 points orgue et vous aurez les
liens pour visualiser les intégralité de
ses cinq dix minutes de ce court métrage
qui diffusait sur internet mais le but
c'est aussi de s'en servir comme d'un
support pour travailler supports
pédagogiques lorsque vous faites des
formations vous griser alors oui le film
est complètement libre droit on l'a
voulu comme ça il n'y a pas de ya pas de
droit dessus donc effectivement nous au
cesu 78 nous l'utilisons lors de nos
formations sont en introduction soit en
conclusion de la séquence sur sur les
arrêts cardiaques
on a développé une formation où on est
prêt à accueillir tous les gens qui
veulent se former spécifiquement sur
l'arrêt cardiaque une petite formation
de deux heures pour pour cette formation
enfin pour l'apprentissage pardon des
gestes de secours sur l'arrêt cardiaque
et puis tous les formateurs de france
peuvent l'utiliser en le prenant sur
notre site ou sur la plateforme qui
l'héberge
pour l'utiliser en formation ou chez
vous le montrer aux enfants votre
famille voilà on ne voie ferrée dans le
film mais a bien évidemment
l'utilisation d'un de ces fameux
défibrillateur on voit vraiment comment
ça se passe comment il faut l'ouvrir le
positionner on en voit de plus en plus
d'ailleurs dans les centres villes les
centres commerciaux
on a suffisamment été analysés alors
c'est utiliser il y en a suffisamment
pas assez mais c'est comme c'est comme
tout mais surtout le gros défaut c'est
le défaut de formation
les défibrillateurs tout le monde sait
qu'il y en a tout le monde visualise à
peu près à quoi ça ressemble mais on ne
sait pas comment ça marche
on ne sait pas qu'il faut masser en même
temps voilà donc l'intérêt de
de ce film c'est vraiment de montrer que
1 1 il faut masser de il faut prévenir
le samu en composant le 15 parce que
plus on va prévenir tôt et plus les
équipes vont venir vous aider
plus tôt et puis il faut aussi des
fibres et les et une utilisation du
défibrillateur quand on voit comme ça en
passant dans la rue on se dit c'est
compliqué mais comme on voit dans le
film c'est relativement simple et tout
est expliqué tout et par le
défibrillateur lui-même les gestes qui
sauvent que savez-vous comment comment
il faut réagir dans la rue si la
situation d'un arrêt cardiaque ce se
présentait à vous c'est notre question
du jour vos réponses il faut appuyer sur
la poitrine le plus fort possible
dégager la dégager les vêtements coupés
si possible il faut mettre la main entre
la poitrine au niveau du trou en dessous
la du trou de la cage thoracique n'ont
jamais repris il faut d'abord joindre
les mains comme ceux ci les épaule
droite se met bien sûr par deux chez la
personne allongée sur le dos et pousser
une vingtaine de répétition avec comme
rythme boney m daddy cool
non je crois que j'ai pu les notions je
les ai eu un jour mais là je exactement
le massage cardiaque non je me remets ta
joie il faut positionner c'est moi comme
ça et faire 30 mouvements comme ça sur
le thorax de la victime et réalisé deux
associations sur dix cycles réaction
vous étiez vous disais oui c'est non
mais c est on le voit nous quand on
quand on fait des formations
c'est quand même des notions qui sont
dans l'inconscient collectif parce qu'on
a tous regardé au moins une fois une
série que ce soit urgence dr house mais
tout ça c'est un geste qu'on a déjà vu
faire qu'on a peur peut-être de faire
mais c'est dans l'inconscient collectif
donc oui ils ont tous à peu près raison
il faut effectivement appuyé sur le
thorax enfin comme le voit jour en voix
au film sur la course et sur sur sur le
site du cesu mais même si on fait mal le
massage cardiaque si on a peur de le
faire et qu'on ne sait pas faire parce
que le temps de faire l'ascension fait
mal si on le fait mal
de toute façon vous ferez mieux que si
vous ne faites rien voilà on va pas être
à 100% efficace
on va pas
optimiser les chances de récupération
mais on va les améliorer si on ne fait
rien dans ces gens vous avez d'autres
projets de ce type pour faire parler
pour justement sensibiliser parce que là
c'était un très gros projet vous avez
mené à son terme assez innovant ou l
autre vidéo casser ces deux ans de
travail donc voila et puis le projet
n'est pas fini le projet c'était de
construire ce court métrage ça c'est
fait maintenant c'est de sensibiliser la
population à apprendre à venir se former
dans les centres
que ce soit chez nous ou ses 8 78 tout
dans les autres centres de formation
donc voilà le projet il est je dirais
que mon projet il est qu'à moitié en
grand la campagne voilà le court métrage
existe maintenant on va essayer de le
diffuser au maximum
et puis après on verra mais oui il ya
d'autres choses à faire et vous aurez
l'occasion de revenir en plateau mais
rira responsable pédagogique du cesu 78
donc auteur notamment de ce film à
actions visibles sur internet qui
sensibilise à l'importance des gestes et
qui sauvent vous pouvez en visualiser
l'intégralité en plus il est libre de
droit vous pouvez même le partager et
ensuite suivre la formation bien
évidemment il faut le voir ta locaux il
faut le partager
les vacances sont maintenant bien
terminée tout autre sujet 1 pour
certains s'étaient même en tout cas la
première fois qu'il découvrait la mer
sur la plage de ouistreham dans le
calvados 5000 enfants de toute
l'ile-de-france notamment des saint
quentinois ont été invités comme chaque
année par le secours populaire c'était
le 20 août
retour sur ce moment fort en émotion
la mer est très grande et plein de
crabes c'est la petite phrase que l'on a
pu entendre en cette fin du mois d'août
du côté de ouistreham 5000 enfants de
l'île de france ont profité d'une
journée à la mer et pour certains
c'était une première fois
parmi ces cinq mille enfants déjeunent
d'elancourt de guyancourt de magny les
hameaux de trappes des clayes-sous-bois
ou encore de saint cyr l'école danse sur
la plage concert de djembé et de
tambours ont rythmé cette journée à
laquelle se sont associées de plusieurs
partenaires dont l'éditeur vie si noir
rue du monde qui a remis les libre aux
enfants en 2014 puis de 35 journées de
ce type ont été organisés en france par
le secours populaire
quelques cinquante mille enfants en ont
profité la journée des oubliés des
vacances existe depuis 97
culture nous poursuivons cette édition
avec la galerie de l'histoire du château
de versailles primes et les architectes
qui ont conçu cette galerie ont reçu le
prix de l'international architecture
award 2014 la cérémonie est organisée
chaque année par le musée d'architecturé
de design de chicago le centre européen
pour la chute lecture l'art le design et
l'urbanisme de dublin et la société
d'édition metropolitan artpress cent
quatorze lauréats 7 en france dont celui
ci donc vous voyez les images le projet
de la galerie de l'histoire a été
achevée il ya deux ans il permet aux
visiteurs de parcourir en salles
l'histoire du site avec maquettes
reconstitution en 3d c'est l'originalité
qui l'a emporté pour l'un de ses
concepteurs il a expliqué un floral
parfait mais le projet je pense que déjà
il ya près violent parce que j'ai la
première fois je te dirais que les raids
à l'intérieur de cette interview de ce
lauréat de ce prix et puis en face au
château de versailles toujours avec
cette association avec la maison dior
cette fois ci une toile monumentale de
l'artiste pierre delavie dissimule en ce
moment les travaux de rénovation du
pavillon dufour
sur cette toile en trompe l'oeil des
photographies des modèles historiques et
contemporains de la maison dior à la
toile restera en place jusqu'en mars
2015 la date de à la fin du chantier
prochaine édition du journal demain même
heure comme chaque vendredi nous
reviendrons notamment sur les temps
forts de cette semaine
excellente soirée